welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I'm your host Mike comer today
you'll see some of my games we had kids
beginner championship the other day and
a guy won the K through three
championship so I decided to challenge
them and see if I still got what it
takes
so I got the white pieces so here we go
right starts out the move
efore hopefully that's what you guys
play black counters with E 5 I play the
move Bishop to c4 the reason why I play
this is to try to induce him into
getting into the fried liver attack
because if you just start out Knight f3
they'll play Knight to c6 and then when
you play Bishop to c4 they'll see what
you're doing that you want to get your
Knight to g5 however if you play Bishop
to c4 first then they'll think the
knight to f6 looks like a pretty natural
move here and it attacks the pawn so now
I play the move Knight to f3 attacking
the pawn and going for Knight to g5 but
he probably only thinks I'm attacking
this pawn so that's a good way to try to
trick your opponent in the first couple
moves so you can get the the fried liver
attack oh and it's played Bishop to c4
on move 2 and then Knight f3 so of
course black plays on Knight to c6 and
so knowing that then you know the move
I'm going for Knight to g5 now I have
two players attacking this f7 square
alright so the most natural way to
combat the fried liver attack is d5
however he did not know this so he plays
Queen to e7 so how should we take on f7
here with the knight or the bishop
well if you take with the bishop its
check so that's probably the way to do
it and so now the King King goes to
safety and so now I have a piece of mine
it deep in his territory that's
currently under attack by the Queen
the only defender is this vulnerable
knight on g5 all right that can be
easily kicked away by the move h6 so
what moves should we be considering here
how about retreating the bishop okay
because because he's kind of he already
did his job right he took the pawn he
delivered the check but now he's very
vulnerable down in our enemies territory
where he's being attacked so let's flee
him the safety okay so he's ico could be
fine and so now with my bishop leaving
f7 who's primed to just swoop in there
with a check the knight yes then I
checks king over fork okay so now Queen
to d6 Knight back to f7 to attack the
Queen Queen to b4 we could attack the
Queen again or we could just get safe
you know we're castled we're safe we're
awesome d6 knight back protects the pawn
a Bishop to g4 so there's a couple moves
we can do here f3 but that would leave
us susceptible to checks on this
diagonal we could move the Queen to
safety or we can do do something that
we've been talking about make threat
greater or equal to this attack so he's
attacking my queen
so we can attack his queen all right so
he takes my queen and then I can capture
his queen back unfortunately if you
thought he's not doing so well right now
it just gets worse
so Knight takes the pawn that's not good
so what move should we play as white
here welcome Mario so what move should
we play as white here you notice or any
of his pieces hanging essentially I'm
free where they if they get taken nobody
can get captured back do you see Mario
you don't see all right well keep
looking you'll see it which piece of
Black's can just be taken for free right
here now Bishop yeah we just take the
bishop okay fortunately the knight comes
in because the rook has no place to go
but the bishop protects it so so always
look to see you know before you make
dubious moves to see hey if I put my
piece there can it get captured
all right so night night out night
threads the the fork he sees that Knight
threatens the pawn defy that's kind of
where I was going anywhere so that was
nice so now I got two guys attacking c7
he protects it again so I got a check in
there king f7 Knight back now he's
making a threat of his own okay just
cause you're getting blown out in the
game as we'll see in the next game here
there's always chances for comebacks so
even though he's getting whooped right
now Bishop to c5 attacks the pond so we
should do something about that
any ideas where we can do about this
move what's the best way to counter
Bishop the c5
and it's an attacking move pawn to d4
excellent yeah keep keep your attack
rolling and excellent so now it goes
here which is another in other herbs as
they say yeah and yeah I take I see it
that's it politics rook takes and then
Knight up just get try to get a mating
net going here we want to get the game
done as soon as possible here so King
King up protect it h6 well unfortunately
King can't take protective pieces Rick H
/ pawn take so when he takes it's too
little too late and now there's Kings on
the side of the board we have very
simple checkmate here so we can just
bring this rook finally into the game on
f1 and yeah you got the pod for kit so
so he never he never stops there which
is good as we'll see in this next game
you just keep playing until till the
bell rings pretty much and then we get
this see where you weren't checking in
these positions if we check then the
King gets out of the off the back row
off that off that side file and into the
game so we just play rook to g3 and keep
them forever on this h-file and then
checkmate okay so not too not too good
but let's see a game that's kind of
similar to that one where you know a guy
never gives up and maybe a comeback
happens cuz he's not playing a guy you
know as good as me so let's check that
one out
all right so so white plays d4 this is a
game begin against a very
beginner players you know what the what
White's rating is on a chest i com it's
like 900 are just like I'm and he's
playing somewhat very similar to the
hitters rating
alright so II 45 Queen to h5 would
probably see this a lot okay so he's
attacking our pawn our good friend st.
Louis resident he Corey Nakamura used to
play this move he cents grew out of it I
guess so Queen to h5 and attacks this
pawn so natural moves like Knight f6
attacking the Queen no good and another
Mario this is PI Mario's favorite move
in this position g6 unfortunately Queen
takes pawn check and you just lost your
rook so in this move I mean shoot you
can just play Knight to c6 d6 whatever
you like alright so g6 queen takes and
now a fork is in play Bishop e7 Queen
takes the rook and now the knight is in
a pin so does anybody have any idea what
the best move for a black is here it's
really funny anybody now you just want
to say oh man he's good this guy's good
good well obviously he's attacking our
Knight right we just lost the rook you
want to be down a knight to king of
eights the only thing we can do I just
hope we don't get made it now by Bishop
h6 so with then we then we proceed with
Wow can we even play that so after d3
now he's threatening Bishop to h6
and adults I don't see it alright so
maybe he played the best move he's like
okay you take my rook hey you know guess
what
take my knight - I'm getting out of here
I have been but he plays Bishop to f8
here so you know he just takes more
stuff he's got this bishop in a pen he
should be thinking about getting this
Bishop to h6 and getting some good stuff
happening here but all right
so Queen takes the pawn but it's always
good to take stuff you know it's a
Bishop to c4 excellent what's he
threatening checkmate right this is a
very pivotal Square for black in the
opening f7 because it's only protected
by the king that's why it's the weakest
Square and all of chess okay and so so
so he stops it with Bishop to e6
so Bishop takes pawn so we should be
able to see this this combination where
Bishop takes the bishop pawn takes and
it removes the defender of g6 check now
King to d7 so now now what's in all
right Queen check again Queen blocks so
we're up so much material you know you
might you might think about trading but
you know you know you're still on the
attack so either way is fine queen up
Knight to c6 so white decides to get
some of his pieces off the back row
playing now but he does in a very
suspect way Knight to f3 I'm not very
good because well I can just take it
however black he's got his own threats
happening here so he wants to play
he's like forget the free night I'm
gonna go for the fork okay so black
should have obviously taken the free
night all right so Knight to be four so
now why is like old man my
now he realizes my night is under attack
and he's threatening night takes seat to
check I can't believe he sees it but he
does
so what move can we do to kill two birds
with one stone here
save our Knight and protect c2 Kevin's
got it you guys got it back there how
can we save the knight and protect c2
simultaneously so if we bring that night
out unfortunately he could take our
knight on f3 so we got to move our
knight to somewhere that protects c2 can
this night go anybody to protect c2 your
excellent d4 right all right so now
blacks playing really good he's like
okay I forgot how to play but now I
remember again all right so so look this
Knight is the fancy 2 however he's in
he's pretty close to a you know blacks
territory so he's easier to attack so c5
attacks the night so now if we move our
Knight
guess what Knight takes C to check this
coming and we don't like that so this is
a great idea example of when to make a
threat greater or equal to your
opponent's threat so he's a threaten or
night if we move her night we get fort
so that's off the table so what should
we attack here any ideas who should
white attack in this position the night
excellent
c3 are you know a3 well whatever they're
both they're both fight
all right so a3
obviously yes yes as I looked closer see
three doesn't work because uh because at
ninety three check King up and then I'll
buy by night all right so that's why
when you make a threat like that
you got to calculate hard and luckily
why did you pick the right pawn a three
all right so he takes takes and now III
so now black even though he's down so
much he's still generating a counter
play okay he's threatening check and
whatever
alright so white just gets out of there
he castles the safety now if you were
playing black what would you play well I
don't even know so so you never want to
get rid of you know by trading these
pawns but if you do play e2 and he plays
rook to e1 how can you save it anybody
have any ideas I don't I think he's just
gone so maybe it may be taken with check
is fine
all right rook takes and now Queen takes
b4 so now we got a Czech Kings on the
run so we can't take this bishop because
he has two defenders so now he's gonna
try to distract the Queen
well maybe not maybe he's gonna try to
try to win that pawn so King up to her
protect it not very good so he's decided
I'm moving him back
Queen check again King back up rook
check so they're doing a little dance
and now he moved King to ei t' so now
you know if you're playing white here
you know you could consolidate but
you're got such a great attack he
decides he's not gonna do that
you couldn't even come up here and
threaten checkmate alright but instead
see three so he's gonna try to get the
Queen out of there so now it worked so
Queen to b3 so now the Queen has left
the diagonal and we're free to take the
bishop with check and now King up Queen
check and now we can take the rook
alright so now look at how much white is
up okay this is especially important in
these beginner games okay even at the
thirteen fourteen fifteen hundred level
never resign
all right you still have a queen you
could still get a stalemate
theoretically there's no reason to
resign make your opponent beat you until
the bitter end okay so he's up by a lot
like a lot but you know black he's
determined he's gonna check and he likes
it alright so King F F up so takes it
alright so so he's still doing okay rook
check King up he's still alive he's not
doing okay but he's still alive that's
the most important thing King up rook
check and you see white can never he's
all these checks are just he's just
going around in circles he's never
putting on the final mate here so now
he's tag-team on here and so now we
should be able to see a checkmate for
white here all right what do you think
like the first move would instantly be
like what move did you just play Queen
f7 to attack what the pawn right so why
doesn't he just take the pawn okay all
right so then if King goes up we'll
check him and then hopefully mate him
right all right let's say so wait let's
say he goes this way okay
all right can we find a checkmate here
alright I can find a checkmate that can
you you can get all your pieces involved
you know it doesn't have to be the Queen
and the rook the whole time you know
yeah yeah I'm just gonna end it yeah
that's what you should be thinking I'm
just gonna end it not this ring around
the rosey stuff for you know 20 moves
he'll enter pal all right so he
interpose he's feeling good now he's
like I black it and now we have one move
that just ends the game yeah I'll give
it him it's not pawn takes pawn because
because this pawn is doing something
pivotal it's keeping the King out of b4
so did we see checkmate in one move
notice how the Queen got the check on e6
then the other rook brought it up to a 5
it's a team game nobody ever believes me
when I say it but intestines are the
ultimate team sport you need everybody
in here to to bring it home now who
hasn't been getting in these checks
lately
you see checkmate in one mario rook c8
mate thank you and that's it that's game
alright so whenever you have a chance to
checkmate your opponent don't begin for
bishops don't begin three nights and as
look how cool I am just just get it over
with checkmate alright so in the game he
doesn't take the Pawnee place Queen to
e7 check now he takes it and now he's
probably has a variation of that
checkmate that we just showed but
instead I'm gonna get even though I got
this work super story that could just
check and lead them
I'm gonna get another queen look at me
all right
now take your rook then RA if you don't
want to I'll take it all right okay so
now check again King up check so it's
very dangerous but you know it's just
gonna keep going for it
so discovered check he decides he
doesn't need the night which is a
mistake okay so once again we got a
checkmate in two here or something it's
got to be - all right so notice notice
this rook is being great right he's
keeping the king you know on this side
of the board okay so I give you a hand
it's not a Brooke Chuck Kawai right
Knight c3 I mean it looks it looks cool
like a knight check right but but what
did that just do it may die fleeing a
little path for the king I'm sure Knight
to c3 leaves the maid in 11 I don't know
what move of whites doesn't move I'm
eight and 11 but but we have faster we
have made in - Queen to b3
well that might just be made in a1 huh
so we don't even need to do made into
going to be three just ends it and I
won't show how I calculated out me okay
I calculate out that check which is also
mate right yeah I calculate out the
better make it so everything's a mate so
he misses a lot of mates here all right
but now you this H pawn could get a
queen or this could be a queen one he
doesn't even know which one to push all
right so we know he's just taking all
the stuff now white still has checkmate
in two with Queen to b3 check King here
and now where's the checkmate for white
here
there's only one square that leads the
mate and even we get the King involved
obviously the Kings not gonna be doin
the checkmate but he's gonna be queen to
eat - excellent because you got you
Chucky gnome attacking them and
attacking both of his potential flight
squares excellent
alright so Queen takes now he's just i
get i get this queen
I'll get this clean that's fine all
right so so now you know blacks like
well you know I'll throw in my own check
see what you can do about it so he's
like I don't want to do nothing about it
I just want ya alright so Queen check
alright so so I've had some fun with
white here but what should he play here
to have maximum safety for his King in
this position should he go here here are
back to g1 probably g1 is the safest
because if he gets well I can't get
checked again well if he gets checked
again like there then we go here and now
he's got no more potential checks okay
okay but it's a he goes right into the
fire okay right up the King up three so
he saw how black moved his King to the
end of the board so he's thinking I mean
I get my king way up top - and notice
that when the black King got to the back
row it did not turn into anything it's
just it's just various so check King up
so he takes the punt so now white is
like oh man my rooks under attack I'm
gonna play maximum safety here I'm gonna
put the Queen and the rook in the same
line and nothing bad can ever happen
because they're both protecting each
other okay so so we'll see if it works
out for him alright so Queen check hey
King moves check alright so he just
played King - G
six brushing that King up there
was that a good move or a horrible move
yeah pretty bad move right because the
Queen and the rook are in the same line
but they're only protecting each other
if there's nobody in between all right
so it's a devastation Queen takes the
Kings gotta move and then you know what
happens
all right the ultimate come back and
take all its stuff yeah
then the game's over so so that's why
you never give up especially in these
beginner games especially with a shorter
time control time pressure can become a
factor you know just the nerves they
can't put your away and they get
frustrated so so even if you have a
checkmate you know just get it done just
win it and move on to the next one all
right so now we have a game contributed
by a Mario here in this game it's kind
of back and forth where Mario's a force
shake kind of not doing so well then he
gets up and then it flip-flops back and
forth all right
so Mario will give you will give you the
prime spot will give you a on the on the
bottom here all right Mario's our hero
playing black against grant okay here we
go
so white plays out efore black plays a 5
9 f3 attacks the pawn Knight goes to c6
so Bishop to b5 so now I guess Mario
didn't want the double pawn so he plays
Queen to f6 here okay but bringing out
your queen too early sometimes it's not
optimal because it can be attacked so
easily so Knight to c3 so he's already
eyeing at this Knight to d5 square
attacking the Queen
so Mario attacks the Bishop Bishop
retreats notice that white could go
ahead and play Knight to d5 here because
as Queens attacked
all right so Bishop moves
and now he's attacking f7 here the
pivotal square Noorie
so Bishop to b7 and so white finally
does get the move Knight to d5 and and
now mario has to retreat the Queen
however his plan kind of worked because
you know he did not receive double pawns
so that was good so d3 and now if you
were to put your knight on e7 which
Knight would you move this night the one
that hasn't moved or the one that's on
c6 yeah always develop your pieces okay
because you want to get all your pieces
off the back row alright so you can
eventually castle right so 97 I would
even thought about Knight f6 here okay
and notice that night on e7 was doing a
pivotal job here he was protecting this
pawn
so no pawns going alright so he attacks
it right retreats back now takes takes
and now Mario's got a chance you know he
didn't want double pawn so why does he
think that his buddy would he probably
doesn't so he could take and now his uh
his opponent would receive double pawns
and then we can think about Bishop e7
Knight f6 and castling all right but
instead he he's he makes uh make some
retreat and now I guess it's going back
to f6 notice again well he can't attack
Bishop to g5 here or else Queen would
take the b-pawn so maybe he'll try to
place d3 or maybe he'll just get Castle
I said he plays as Knight to g5 alright
so everybody should know why he plays
Knight to g5 attacking the pivotal f7
square he's got one attacker
to attackers that added up to six we
only have one two defenders but they add
up to be way more than six points okay
so what is an idea for black to protect
f7 here there's two different ones one
is direct protection the other is
interference where we're getting
somebody in the way of the bishop
because obviously we can't get anybody
in the way of Knight to f7
because you can jump over so the two
moves we should be considering or Knight
to h6 it just protects up 7 and d5 here
right so white castles and black decides
I'm gonna I'm gonna get out of there
fair enough does whose castle looks
safer whites are blacks whites he's got
all his little pawns in front you cannot
get checked where black can get checked
and he's going to just check him
wherever he sees it I can't wait check
you probably really excited about it so
so barrio moves over and now he tries to
break it open with E 5
so after Queen to g6 white plays f4 all
right so f4 you know it's fine what I
mean we can kind of be a venturous here
right all right so so what can you tell
me about this square f4 here all right
well the one thing I would say about it
is it's on the same diagonal as this
king on b8 interesting so you know a
pawn on f4 really isn't attacking the
king but the bishop or the Queen can so
if we play Queen to f4 here
now we're eyeing the F pawn and
threatening be six check alright but he
just wanted to protect the upon so I
always be looking out for putting your
pieces on the same diagonal file or rank
as the enemy king
that way you could get some discovered
checks pin skewers all kinds of good
stuff
all right that's why we like our King
safe in a castle and by playing the move
f4 for white he's susceptible now to
checks you know alright so he plays
Bishop the c8 attacks the Queen Queen
retreats now Knight to h6 now II 6 so
Mario's like I don't even care
I'm gonna attack your queen it's good
and it stops all the discovered check
shenanigans excellent Mario F Knight to
f5 Queen to h3 now it's safe to take
that pawn and we better take it
pawn takes g4 attacks the night so we
move the knight
and so so now now he plays rook to f2
which I don't really understand but now
now we just said King rook you know he
played playing before he opened up that
long diagonal and now we just put the
rook on the same diagonal as the king so
which move do you think we want to play
here yeah you should have played it
Bishop to c5 threatening Knight takes
bishop pawn takes Bishop takes rook
check if we even want to which we do
want to by the way because sometimes
it's like well I don't even know what
movie could play - all right let's say
you play c3 we would want to after
Knight takes pawn takes we would want to
take it right away even though it's a
pin piece because if we just like well
you know whatever he can get he can
interfere with it well active obviously
with d4 in this instance okay so so we
would want to take it right away so yeah
Mario when you've got his king of rook
on the same diagonal and you've got a
dark square bishop man this is this is
the time to strike
unfortunately he plays Bishop to b4 walk
here - huh
yeah that's a lot of hope chest is I
prefer good moves to hope chest
all right it's a bishop so c3 but it's
okay because you can take take and as I
go yeah look at this I got the the the
pin it's too little too late because
they can get d4 in now whereas in the
other position if he plays Bishop c5
right away you see you can't play d4 all
right would you live and learn right all
right
so d4 but you know even though he missed
this opportunity to win you know
sometimes you know more opportunities
come up maybe just our patient better
better opportunity see baby yeah you
never know
all right so he's offers the Queen trade
I would definitely Queen trade if I was
white here Queen takes pawn takes you
know he's got these double junk pawns
you got the forks the fork pana doesn't
work though cuz it check but it's still
fun to play and maybe we won't see it
alright so yeah if I was white I would
have trained a heartbeat but okay so he
plays a check oh you can't resist a
check right alright and now he blocks
the check yeah and you know now he's got
some pressure on each to it's nice so
now as I was just drove trade now that's
right nothing but now black has all
these nice pawns down here so you got a
strike when you can you know like I mean
what was he thinking was gonna happen
after Queen to g3 check here I mean I
just don't get it was he hope even if
you play like rook the d6
well maybe it's hoping that oh that's
what he was hoping for
alright here's hoping that Mario was so
excited about trading Queens they would
play Queen the d6 now
I'm I'm thinking like a thousand okay so
so he was hoping that he played Queen to
d6 so now if he plays Queen to d6 what
move does white slam on the board here
yeah the bishop to f4 okay yeah-oh no
yeah-oh no and then that yeah so so it
since Mario played a much better move
Bishop to c7 now he's like okay I'll
trade him okay
all right so Knight takes h3 all right
so now Mario's Mario's getting somewhere
he's attacking packing some stuff
one two three four five six one two
three four five six so maybe if he can
win a pawn or something he'll be doing
okay all right Knight attacks the pawn
here so he just takes take take and it
defended the point excellent
so now Mario's up a pawn he's feeling
really good
all right so let's see how long it takes
alright so right gets a pawn back King
up I Rick retreats
so all right so now he plays rook to e8
threatening uh Shaq why not you know or
maybe even stop short to keep that king
back in that back row
all right so Knight to f3 stops the
check
and so now Mario plays rook to e6
threatening a check down here so King to
f2 so far so good
Bishop attacks the night all right fair
enough and now Knight forks the rook and
the bishop no troubles no troubles we
can just get out of it with a rook check
and he does all right excellent all
right so now King King back to the back
row so you still doing okay Mario but
now he plays rook to h6 he's got two
players iron on h2 the rook and the
bishop so let's see what he does here
which is not good because what did Mario
just put the rook in the same Lane as
the bishop
all right so how can how can white take
advantage of this situation where it's
Bishop Knight rook yeah we got we got a
four-time u.s. chess champion yasser
Serra one he knows he wants he wants to
get all the glory here yes sir take
Knight takes the bishop okay you know
because if if it's still in the same
line there's no threat so so Knight
takes Bishop making this threat active
now so if pawn takes Knight Bishop takes
the rook and then white is just crushing
and then if if Bishop takes the pawn
with check
King moves the safety and he's still got
to get out of this situation here so now
he could try Brooke check but then king
takes bishop pawn takes and he still
down a whole piece there's no way to get
out of it so so Mario yeah so in this
position Mario just just move the bishop
to safety and then you don't have to
worry about nothing
sounds good all right